Adam the one phone call you would get
right now where you would have to hang
up and take that phone call is from who
probably my wife Dan because I have not
spoken for a couple of days about romo
Garoppolo if it's related to those will
you hang up on it if you want me to I
certainly will no I don't want you to ok
well the Jimmy is not going anywhere so
I wouldn't feel the need to take that
phone call right now ok get rolling Romo
I would be tempted to hang up on you ok
um and and maybe maybe dr. Hightower
could get me off the phone with you but
sure that you're stuck with me little
bit here let's go back to Garoppolo
social media at four in the morning yeah
help us here separate fact from fiction
well the fact is that Chris not should
we grew up with a post-it the fiction is
somebody else posted the fiction and I
don't know how this sort of thing
happens it's way beyond my technological
mental capabilities to understand it and
grasp it I have enough difficulty just
going live on Facebook but somebody
posted a video saying goodbye to New
England and it's just not true he's not
going anywhere they're not trading him
he was Lee on their roster come this
summer why has in his agent said
anything about it I don't know I don't
know doesn't that clear it up if his
agent I mean Jimmy took down the post or
somebody did button is it still up
Seaton what why is it the agents
responsibility to do that he's under
contract at a church for another year
well just all the buzz around his client
he just comes out and says look you know
my client was hacked and if I was hacked
don't you take that down I don't know
whether it's up or down right now and I
know that his agent is a gentleman by
the name of Don ye who also happens to
represent Tom Brady I know that Don Yee
is a very private person and and he's
also another guy thats actively engaged
involved or monitoring social media so I
don't think he really clear that people
are posting things on his clients
account and
and your Jimmy has said before that his
mom and dad keep him apprised of events
on a need-to-know basis and and I don't
know that they even view this is a
need-to-know basis maybe they do in the
last 60 seconds it just was taken down
so well there you go when you the power
of dan Patrick right sadly absolutely
you and me let's we did it together here
I did show you i'm gonna give you all
the credit there i explained to me
though why the Patriots wouldn't trade
Garoppolo if he couldn't be hotter and
you probably couldn't get more value for
him so why why not um well physically
they're not going to trade him because
there's a few reasons number one I think
he's a great quarterback number 2 Tom
Brady's 40 years old and as great as he
has been and oh and you make yoga means
the greatest quarterback in NFL history
have how many quarterbacks have we seen
have extended success into their footage
now he's different he's undefeated
against even father time but how long
will that continue for a year two years
three years I don't know the answer to
that nobody does right so they have the
most important position and football
secured and they haven't for this year
so after this year it obviously gets
interesting again and I think you always
could procure grapplers rights by using
the franchise tag it's probably not
ideal but I'm sure they could figure out
a way around and again as I mentioned
before the Asian town you represents
both Brady and Garoppolo his allegiance
is to serve both clients but I'm sure
there's a way they can figure it out
looked it they just they place too high
bottom line is they place too high of a
value on Garoppolo and what is the most
important position in sports in my mind
to move on from him and they're not and
that's the deal and I know people are
taking this initially as saying well the
Patriots didn't get their price no
that's that's not accurate I know people
said that the price is trying to be
driven up by saying he's not being true
and that's not accurate what what is
accurate is that they value the position
they love the quarterback they're not
moving on from him and we over on I
think you just backed up over the
Cleveland Browns hopes of getting Jimmy
grop like in here in the background
there so you know then my office is in
the NFL studio and all the noise and
work that goes on here like my office
technically should not be here they have
not given me an office like they did if
you at the mothership so my office is in
this big public rumor there's also to
work activity and I got people moving
things and trucks and noises and tours
coming through and it's almost like
you're like the animal the monkey in the
cage at the zoo with all the tour groups
coming in oh there's the guy in the
phone tweets degrees right over there as
if yeah and you try to talk to whoever
you're talking to while people are
coming over and taking pictures it's
kind of fun what did the Texans and
browns do yesterday I think they made
history I mean have you ever seen a
network like that ever meld and the fact
that you did they both wit is it
possible they both won depends on
English listen what I found fascinating
about it are a few different things
number one on this day last year we were
all talking all about Brock Osweiler and
was down to denver in Houston he picked
Houston and what a big move and he was
the big story on the first day of free
agency and a year later for entirely
different reasons Brock Osweiler still
is the biggest story on the opening day
of free agency and the Houston Texas I
thought that the numbers were job of
just moving on from that because
correction i'm wrong but for weeks we
have speculated what do you do about a
quarterback who's 16 million dollar
guaranteed salary you're stuck with for
next year and everybody just presume
he's on the roster there's nothing he
could do about it because no one's going
to want them and nobody envisioned that
they would say another team in the form
of a second-round draft pick to take the
player and his contract off their hands
which is exactly what they did the
browns who entered yesterday with over a
hundred million dollars of cap space
more than any cap space of any team in
the league basically are dedicating a
lot of that to taking on a player that i
don't think they sought out to get but
now
are you the second round rafic that's
what they wanted they have I think it's
like five picks in the top 65 this year
through in the top whatever it is making
the first two rounds next year they've
got all sorts of extra pics to try to
rebuild this roster so both team to get
what they want out of this but I don't
think anybody envisioned how the texans
could get out of Brock Osweiler of jail
for lack of a better phrase and they did
it they escaped yesterday I don't think
he's going to play for Cleveland though
Adam do you I don't think so either dead
no and the Browns I want to maintain
this is the brown saying it so you
believe what you want so that they've
gotten calls on Brock Osweiler they'd
have to eat some of the salary the
Browns no one's treating for that
contract the way it is I mean the Browns
got a second-round draft pick to trade
for that contract so who Lee Oswald is
not demand like that but i think the
Browns maybe could place him that
contract and hope to move on from him
we'll see I know Bill Polian is very
skeptical that could happen but we'll
see how plays that do I think to do
building their offseason program and
plans for the 2017 season around Brock
Osweiler no I mean we all know that so
it'll be interesting I think Brock
Osweiler is floating in no man's land
right now uncertain of his future the
one thing we do know about his future
he's going to make 16 million dollars
this year guaranteed dancer just to
worry about where he's going to have to
find housing all right it was a year ago
we were talking about Houston or Denver
because the Brock Osweiler and here we
are a year later talking about Houston
or Denver with Tony Romo what's this
come down to well let's be very clear
about this Tony Romo would like to be on
the open market and i don't i don't
think Dallas to be able to trade him and
then some point they can have to release
him here because there's not a team out
there not Denver not Houston that
basically places a premium and is
planning its offseason in 2017 season
around Tony Romo Tony Romo is the bonus
he is the cherry on the ice cream sundae
you're the Houston Texans you're the
Denver Broncos you're proceeding as if
you're not going to have Tony Romo for a
couple of reasons number one you don't
know whether you're going to be able to
get them number two
with his injury history you don't know
if you don't stay healthy even if you do
get them so you've got a plan as if he's
not even going to be there anyway and
then if you do get him then that's great
because you've got a chance to hopefully
keep him upright and healthy and have a
good season and have him get one last
hurrah here before his NFL career ends
but I can tell you the Denver is not
counting on having him long term
Houston's not counting on having a long
term I don't do there's a team in the
NFL is counting on having him long term
so these teams are going to go about
make their plans right now the Broncos
plans are the two quarterbacks to have
on their roster so ever send me in a
passionate lynch the protections plans
are the two quarterbacks on their roster
Tom savage and Brandon Weeden people
could say oh come on but again what else
you gonna do these are the options right
now broncos traded up in the draft last
year to go get Paxton Lynch they like
sort of simian detection is like Tom
savage you came out and played pretty
well for Bill O'Brien they've got
Brandon Weeden in a backup kind of role
and they'll go out and get another
quarterback at some point whether it's
20 Rome or not anything we need to be
aware of to keep an eye on today any big
possibility aside from the real no
decision if that even happens you know a
lot of big-name defensive players out
there right now Dan dr. Hightower
Johnathan Hankins Dontari Poe Bennie
Logan Adrian Peterson still floating
around out here Colin Kaepernick's still
floating around out there I think that
those players might take a little bit
more time than some of these defensive
players but I think that as we've come
to see in this league just because it
seems like it might be a slower day
especially compared to yesterday doesn't
mean it actually will turn out that way
how much sleep did you get last night I
got I got you two hour intervals it was
pretty good yeah not bad you sound like
you're jacked up on coffee uh I don't
really die well it is a latte coffee and
I you know Sherlock a coffee I don't
know that you consider that maybe it is
maybe not even though i'm putting my
body there may be some caffeine though
yeah a little bit maybe smooth thanks
for spending time and then later den
time night buddy thank you I will be in
touch that's Adam Schefter I don't think
you've got a good office space there the
mothership you know there's budget
he cuts and they can't give him a good
office there you got trucks backing up
the Dan Patrick show weekday morning on
audience